[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisir tout de suite le sommaire de ce
jeudi 27 septembre l'espace 50 ans
accueille la bulle leur local prêté à
l'association anima sauce pendant six
mois il sera ouvert tous les samedis et
proposera de multiples activités
françoise de salles de l'air sera avec
nous pour en parler ou partir en forêt à
la découverte du brame du cerf comme
tous les ans de mi septembre à mi
octobre c'est la saison des amours pour
le roi de la forêt l'espace rambouillet
est un endroit idéal pour les observer
et les entendre un rassemblement harley
et plein d'animations samedi aliens de
bailly l'association un geste en plus
organise une journée américaine pour
récolter des fonds et partager un moment
de convivialité
comme tous les ans le cerf de la forêt
de rambouillet cherche l'attention des
femelles l'espace rambouillet propose
une balade pour les observer et écouter
le fameux brame du cerf
isabelle carré lisse cause les a
rencontrés lors d'une virée champêtre
pour le cerf le mois de septembre c'est
le début de la saison des amours
alors pour faire des rencontres ils
donnent de la voix
entendre à bruxelles que le cri poussé
par le cerf donc le mal pour défier des
autres serres est aussi séduire les
biches tous les ans à cette période de
l'année à savoir entre mi septembre
début octobre
c'est la période de reproduction de
l'espèce le cerf et durant cette période
va pousser ce cri fameux on appelle le
bramont s'il sait se faire remarquer des
biches et se montre plus timide avec
l'humain dans la forêt de rambouillet
c'est pas facile de les rencontrer à
cette époque de l'année les entendre et
l' avantage à l'espace rambouillet c'est
que le dispositif installé permet de les
voir avec quasi certitude
lors des visites que l'organisme
l'espace rambouillet propose des visites
en autonomie mais aussi des moments
spéciaux le matin ou le soir sur
réservation
et bien c'est très prisé effectivement
est là cette année on est pratiquement à
100% réservation si les gens sont encore
intéressés ils peuvent venir y assister
en journée en toute liberté
ne reste plus qu'à penser à prendre sa
paire de jumelles et se montrer discret
pour peut-être apercevoir coup de foudre
entre cervidés l'espace k y accueille la
bulle en local investi par anima sauce
qui ouvrira chaque samedi à partir du 6
octobre
françoise de celle de l'air bonjour
bonsoir vous êtes la présidente dany
masseaux ce l'association existe depuis
pouvez vous nous expliquer en quoi elle
consiste alors en fait un animal c'est
un regroupement d'associations
culturelles et artistiques du territoire
et anne ses objectifs c'est de
participer à la dynamique culturelle de
saint quentin en yvelines soit en
accompagnant des projets qui sont déjà
existants qui sont en formalisation soit
en créant des des projets donc soit un
espace comme la bulle soit nous avons un
autre projet de création de festivals
donc ça peut être quelque chose de plus
de plus mon parti stick mais une
création d'un vrai événement local et
l'idéal est venu comment comme nous
avions 20
semble être si l'association alors
l'idée est venue en fait non pas de la
création de l'association mais
auparavant parce qu'avant de créer cette
association nous nous sommes regroupés
pendant deux ans et nous avons travaillé
notamment avec lui vs q c'est à dire
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et avec des étudiants en master pour en
avoir rencontré beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes pour essayer de tester un peu
les échanges qu'on avait entendu et qui
de la part des dirigeants associatifs
locaux
tendez tout ce vert à peu près les mêmes
conclusions c'est que
mutualisation pas assez nos compétences
nos expériences et que c'était un manque
sur saint quentin en yvelines qui a un
vivier extrêmement riche de
d'associations et d'acteurs locaux donc
la semaine prochaine vous aurez un local
à rien pour vous il va se passer quoi
dans ce modèle alors ce local sera un
lieu de rendez vous pour les habitants
donc ça sera local libre d'accès avec
des activités gratuites extrêmement
éclectique puisque animations regroupe
des associations qui certes sont
culturelles et artistiques mais dans
tous les domaines artistiques ou
culturelles donc voilà ça ira de d'un
atelier de danse et dieu sait qu'on
danse nous sommes riches en association
donc ça sera de toutes sortes de danses
se seront aussi dé des petites formes
théâtrales y aura aussi des mini
concerts de musiques actuelles de jazz
il y aura aussi des ateliers
participatifs notre association regroupe
beaucoup beaucoup d'associations en
partenariat et nous sommes également
partenariat avec des associations de le
ss c'est à dire l'économie sociale et
solidaire
donc voilà ils vont pouvoir aussi à
investir les lieux pour y présenter des
ateliers participatifs
c'est à dire que tous les samedis on
pourra venir danser faire du théâtre et
c'est la nausée
donc il y aura une programmation qui qui
est en réalisation et cette
programmation sera affichée d'un samedi
sur l'autre sur la vitrine
donc au début nous imaginons que le
public sera assez volatile que les
passants passé comme voilà comme leurs
noms l'indiquent mais petit à petit
pourront prendre des habitudes et
essayer de voile à devenir sur un
créneau et donc de s'installer sur une
activité qui durera entre un quart
d'heure et 20 minutes puisque le concept
c'est bien sûr de répondre aux attentes
du public et le public l'avait être
assez spécifique et donc c'est une
première ce partenariat avec le centre
commercial alors c'est une première en
tout cas le projet de la bulle
un espace
ouvert à tous gratuit dans un centre
commercial
ça c'est une première nous ne l'avons vu
nulle part ailleurs le partenariat avec
l'espace saint quentin avait déjà
commencé il y a deux ans parce que
animations accompagne un festival
étudiant qui s'appelle le festival à 100
c est dans ce cadre là nous avions déjà
commencé un partenariat avec l'espace
saint quentin et vous constituer un
réseau d'associations si on est une
association peut toujours vous rejoindre
absolument si on a une association peut
nous rejoindre et pas seulement les
associations puisque notre une de nos
caractéristiques c'est que nous
accueillons des associations mais aussi
des habitants et aussi des entreprises
puisqu'on a le plaisir d'avoir la
librairie du pavé du canal qui est
adhérente dany masseaux donc si on veut
votre programme vous avez un site
internet c'est une semaine sur l'autre
mais il ya peut-être des rangs des
rendez vous un peu phares prévues déjà
alors il ya déjà des rendez vous prévus
notamment ceux du 6 octobre nous avons
un site internet donc on peut nous
retrouver sur le site je crois qu'ils
les aient pas justement cela qui va
s'afficher
donc on peut nous retrouver sur notre
site et on va retrouver la programmation
très rapidement le 6 octobre dont joe
d'ouverture sera consacrée à la
présentation du lieu parce que bien sûr
c'est un lieu qui interpelle c'est un
lieu un peu étonnant donc voilà donc on
va aller beaucoup de vendée des passants
et des habitants pour leur expliquer
quel est l'objectif
et pourquoi ils sont invités à venir
dans ce lieu entre 11 heures et 19
heures tous les samedis et et puis à 17
heures le 6 octobre
on proposera un concert jazz donc qui
sera fait par l'association color jazz
band qui est une association d'elancourt
donc juste pour préciser
donc c'est dans l'espace ans quentin c
où exactement alors ça se trouve à l'est
des drapiers alors on connaît pas
vraiment les noms d aller dans l'espace
saint quentin b donc ça se trouve en bas
c'est extrêmement facile à trouver
c'est entre la boutique yves rocher et
la boutique jacqueline riu très bien
merci française de celle de lèse on est
revenu sur nous
plateau rendez vous donc samedi 6
octobre pour découvrir la bulle et ses
activités plus d'informations sur site
internet que vous avez vu s'afficher et
merci au revoir merci bonsoir
le conservatoire municipal des heures de
montigny le bretonneux présentera
l'exposition phylogénie utopique de
l'artiste caroline kennerson de la
peinture du dessin et des gravures qui
questionne le corps jusque dans ses
cellules
à découvrir dès aujourd'hui jusqu'au 20
octobre
l'espace albert camus entame une série
de matchs d'improvisation deux équipes
s'affrontent dans un combat théâtrale à
l'ambiance explosive le premier catch
d'impro se joue samedi 29 septembre à
20h30
rambouillet fête la saint lubin tous les
deux ans depuis 1990 la ville
reconstitue l'ambiance des grandes
foires agricoles de l'époque
cette année c'est le premier seigneur du
château géhanne bernier qui sera mise à
l'honneur cette 15e édition se déroulera
toute la journée du samedi 29 septembre
lieux mêmes de bailly sera rock'n'roll
szendy les lieux accueillent une journée
spéciale organisée par l'association un
geste en plus concerts jeux pour enfants
cours de country les animations seront
nombreuses et ouverte à tous point fort
de la journée les baptêmes de moto en
harley pour les enfants en collaboration
avec l'association rock and oil
l'objectif de la journée de récolter des
fonds l'association souhaite offrir un
fauteuil roulant adapté à la piscine
municipale de saint cyr afin qu'elle
soit accessible à tous on attend
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde on
veut vraiment faire une journée aussi
oublié de faire oublier tous les
problèmes aux gens d'enfants différents
comme nous
ou des valides aussi c'est vraiment
ouvert ça permet aussi qu'on se
mélangent et quand on voit leur sourire
quand il monte sur les motos y'a pas
mieux quoi ils sont contents ils sont
heureux ils se sentent comme tout le
monde et est celle avantage d'organiser
ces journées c'est pour eux qu'on les
fait avant toute chose c'est fait aussi
pour récolter des fonds mais c'est aussi
pour leur faire plaisir avant toute
chose et bien évidemment la ryder cup se
poursuit golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines samedi retrouver la deuxième
partie des affrontements duo et dimanche
place aux simples avec en conclusion la
remise des trophées
et si vous n'avez pas réussi à vous
procurer des places vous avez la fan
zone au centre commercial espace saint
quentin
nous les avons découverte la semaine
dernière les féminines du club de
pétanque de montigny entrent dans la
compétition
première journée de tournoi interclubs
régionales samedi elles affronteront
l'équipe de mini le roi et pour notre
rendez vous hors des yvelines direction
le musée picasso dans le 3e
arrondissement de paris l'exposition
picasso chef-d'oeuvre donne l'occasion
de découvrir ou redécouvrir le
redécouvrir les plus grands toiles de
l'artiste espagnol jusqu'au 13 janvier
avant goût dans ce reportage de nos
confrères via grand paris avec ses mains
jointes
son regard concentré et son costume
coloré l'arlequin à 6 de pablo picasso
est une toile emblématique de l'artiste
espagnol
c'est la première fois que le tableau
est exposé à paris peinture dessin
sculpture des dizaines d'oeuvres
célèbres du maître sont présentées au
musée picasso plus qu'une rétrospective
l'exposition entend répondre à cette
question comment une oeuvre devient
telle chef-d'oeuvre l'exposition picasso
chef-d'oeuvre est une exposition qui
porte sur alice
duchesneau chez picasso c'est un peu
comment les chefs-d oeuvre de picasso
sont devenus des chefs-d'oeuvre donc on
a rassemblé des pièces exceptionnelles
venus de collections internationales
publiques et privées comme derrière moi
l'arlequin de balle et chaque salle à la
fois nous montre comment picasso travail
à ses chefs-d'oeuvre quel est son
processus créatif quels sont les autres
oeuvres qui viennent accompagner la
naissance du chef-d'oeuvre et on raconte
aussi comment ces chefs-d'oeuvre
deviennent chef-d'oeuvre par leur
exposition la presse la réception cas
critiques auxquelles elles ont donné
dans un parcours chronologique on
découvrira le génie créatif de picasso
comme ce tableau science et charité pas
en 1897
à seulement 16 ans vous découvrirez
aussi comment les demoiselles d'avignon
sont devenue iconique bien longtemps
après leur réalisation
artiste prolifique l'exposition relate
aussi la vision que picasso avait du
chef-d'oeuvre
picasso avait certainement une
définition très peu académique du shader
puisque on le voit assez rapidement
pratiquée la série de chefs-d'oeuvre
donc se dire il ne recherche pas le
chef-d'oeuvre comme disons morceau de
bravoure oeuvre ultime de l'artiste mais
au contraire il va montrer qu'il est
capable d'en faire plusieurs donc
picasso avait en fait une idée peut-être
que c'est son oeuvre totale qui devait
faire chef-d'oeuvre puisqu'il disait que
tenir son affaire son avis c'est comme
tenir son journal
donnez moi un musée et je le remplis ray
disait pablo picasso avec cette
magnifique exposition l'artiste à qui
l'on prête plus de cent mille oeuvres
nous le prouve
admirablement c'est la fin de votre 7,8
loisirs merci nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]
oh